يغيب عن دهني كثيرين ان قائمه الاحكام
والشروط التي نوافق عليها دون قراءه اي
بند فيها تمنح الشركات حقا بيع البياناتنا
مقابلات السعيره محدده وفقا
لستي عفوا يبلغ متوسط سعر المعلومه
الواحده المتعلقه بالحاله الصحيه 26 سنه
اللافت انها الاعلى سعرا بين باقي
البيانات سعره نقطه البيانات المتعلقه
بالحاله الاجتماعيه 12 سنه اذا كنت خاطبا
او على وشك الزواج في ما تبلغ ثلاثه سنتات
فقط اذا كنت تزوجت حديثا او مطلقه
اما اذا كنت تتوقع مولودا جديدا هناك نقطه
البيانات تساوي 12 سنترا اما العمر والجنس
ف يساوي يعني سنه واحده فقط شركه مثل ميتا
ستتحول هذه السنتات الى ملايين اذا باعت
الشركه معلومه واحده بقيمه خمسه سنتات
ستكسب مئه مليون دولار امريكي من الحسابات
النشطه على منصه فيسبوك
فات الميعاد ستتحول لاحقا لمليارات بعد ان
تتبع وتحلل شركات التصوير سلوك ملكي هذه
البيانات وتقدمها لشركات اخرى
بعرض منتجاتها وخدماتها على الملصه لا
تتعد اذا تكرر لك ظهور اعلان لشركه سفريات
على فيسبوك اذا كنت تتابع حسابات تنشر
محتوى عن السفر